[Music]
so so here there's made all kinds of
claims there about gender identity
I understand gender very very clearly to
be about a political system gender is
what I would call the cultural wing of
male domination and male dominated
society we might want to call it
patriarchy so Jen's is actually about
normalizing certain codes of appearance
and behavior and norms and attributes
according to whether you're male or
female so we can see that the young
girls are basically socialized to be
feminine and boys are socialized to be
masculine and this is all about
reproducing a set of power relations
between between these two what we could
call classes of people I don't think
there's any evidence whatsoever that any
of us have this kind of innate gender
identity that that's that's a term that
again it's been kind of used as a
narrative and it's been very
successfully used as a narrative to try
and persuade people that we have some
kind of innate you know Bruce or now
Caitlyn Jenner refers to himself as
having a female soul for example there's
you know where does this soul reside
what what is it we can see that for
Bruce Jenner who then makes this claim
of being a woman that manifests itself
by doing you know a magazine photoshoot
wearing some kind of like I don't know
like white a corset and wig and makeup
trying to make this claim that that he's
a woman well I would challenge him and I
would challenge Heather as well to
actually tell me what a woman is if it's
just down to that any male can claim to
be a woman because of some sort of
feeling I really want to I want to know
what what do they say that a woman is
because I understand what a woman is is
an adult human female and it's based on
that definition is based very clearly on
our sex bodies and women who who you
know who are born into a patriarchal
society grow up with all kinds of
disadvantages
stereotypes inflicted on us the whole
processes of feminization inflicted on
us male violence against women inflicted
on us and I think it's I think for
so-called trans women then to treat
womanhood as if it's at some kind of
costume that can be put on you know
because of some kind of fantasy of being
a woman and fantasy of femininity I
think is yet another boundary violation
of of women I'm gonna necessarily come
back in just two seconds to to Heather
there as you can both imagine just one
particular thing in Heather's statement
that I wanted to just run past you earth
which is the statement that questioning
someone's self declared gender identity
is I think use the word rude you know
discourteous and that sense that's
clearly something that you don't accept
as a boundary you feel that that's
basically growing off a boundary that
shouldn't actually be there I think we
absolutely have to question it because I
think that whole notion that this is
something that can't be questioned and
we see that an increasingly a really
hostile climate to women who are raising
concerns about this incredibly hostile
you know people bringing trans activist
bringing vexatious prosecutions against
women for raising these concerns attempt
to shut down I mean this is really
amazing to me that this event has
happened seemingly without a big you
know protest outside of it the the very
very censorious and increasingly you
know really aggressive hostile climate
that is that is being directed at women
who raise these concerns I think it's I
think it's all the more important that
tells me that actually what we're doing
is something something very important
and we do have to challenge and question
claims to claims made by men that
they're that they're women because it's
producing all kinds of harms we can see
in terms of women's sports women's
prisons women's refuges across a whole
different range of areas that that that
this is a very this is a violation I
would say of women's boundaries so a lot
to take on and take in there I think
Heather but could I come back you reply
yes I mean I most of the so-called
debates that is hostile is based on
misinformation about transgender people
and taking a example of a transgender
person who isn't pleasure
I'm saying that applies to everyone
who's transgender now in terms of just
coming back about the gender identity is
a bit like saying to someone about their
sexuality no you can't be gay no you
can't be a lesbian etc or you can't be
bi say it isn't I actually like I I say
that that is actually something you
can't be he's ridiculous and a gender
identity
there is a revolutionary purpose a
reason why gender identity arose it was
from primate brain development actually
to be a head start to children learning
in in primates and because it's all
about social structure that was a gender
I against he probably arose from that
but the gender identity doesn't define
what women should be it just happens
that my gender identity that was female
or his female I just happen to learn all
the stereotypes and everything else or
be bombarded with them just like other
women are and one of the things is I
won't have anyone judge me first like
the one of the more bizarre things that
you have from the radical anti trans
people is that sort like saying we you
don't look like a woman
etc well it's like surely that's a
backtrack on feminism isn't it's like
saying what a woman should look like or
we should police people that go into
bathrooms etc based upon their
appearance and you know comically almost
like I've had state allies to my to me
being misgendered because they thought
oh this person hanging around with
Heather who's transgender and out as
transgender
they must be transgender too and you
know that that's just ridiculous so I
think I think we can dress up these you
know this very recent very current
social phenomenon of transgenderism and
the claims around gender identity I you
know I think that we can I think that
you know that can be dressed up with all
kinds of cod science but I will draw
your attention to the work of Gina Ripon
who's recently written a book dispelling
these myths about the kind of sexed
brain and these really insulting claims
that you know there's a pink brain and a
blue drain
there's a mind of thing so I think we
know I think I think we can you know we
can dispel that I think we have to
understand things that happen as social
trends and when we look at the referrals
of young people to gender identity
clinics we can see that that has
absolutely rocketed up in the you know
in the last sort of five to ten years
there's been an increase of young women
in particular with what's termed you
might have come across this term rapid
onset gender dysphoria which is a gender
dysphoria that they're affected by the
kind of distress that they're that
they're experiencing in their usually in
this sort of like early early to mid
teens that has gone up by that they've
been president presenting at gender
identity clinic there's been an increase
of around 4,000 percent in just a few
years so I think we really have to
question this notion of a kind of
evolutionary blah blah blah because what
we're seeing just as we saw with
generations before I remember you know
when you know when I was growing up I
remember my mother's generation we're a
very medic medicated generation a lot of
women as sort of housewives then were on
antidepressants that was a phenomenal
phenomenon of those days then later on
we had eating disorders particularly
affecting you know young women teenage
girls then obviously we've seen
self-harm and I would see all these
phenomena that we're seeing now like
young women experiencing huge distress
around their bodies in when I was in the
States recently I heard from a nurse in
marrying in a hospital in Marion County
who told me that they were conducting
between four and six double mastectomies
every day on young women on the healthy
bodies of young women so I think this is
this is something that is very
concerning to me in terms of a social
trend that has very harmful consequences
and that seems to be wheeled in by using
these kind of ideas of authenticity and
you know gender identity there's all
kinds of very serious harms being done
particularly to young lesbians so I
think that's something that might want
to talk about for a very quick repose
from ethics of well you must make sure
that we don't lose sight of the plastic
surgery but Heather Geena rippen's
actual point was actually gender
identity is something that appears to
have developed actually in the womb as
in a focus on which gender you will
she learned from her points and it's a
very important point is that the brain
is plastic as in it's moldable and it
learns and it changes according to how
it is taught etc and that is where a
gender brain might come in is actually
the stereotypes that you learn well
since the word plus an eclair of course
enables us if we feel a segue to what we
want to talk about for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you